STEVEN ROTHSTEIN:
Welcome, everybody.
It's my great
pleasure to introduce
Eric, recently from
Citizen Schools.
I met Eric about five
or six years ago.
And there were two things
that really stood out.
I was there at Citizen
Schools because we
had several volunteers
from Google who had really
engaged with the program
and was very excited.
And I was told
hey, why don't you
reach out and find out
what they're doing?
And there were two things
that struck me right away.
One is how incredibly
analytic they are.
And they talk about
measures and outcomes,
and it was like I was at Google.
It was really interesting.
And then the second thing
was, everybody was amazing,
Eric himself included.
It's just an amazing
group of people.
And I felt like I was
at home, even though I
wasn't inside
Google at the time.
We started to have a closer
and closer relationship
with Citizen Schools.
We became one of the biggest
contributor of volunteers
to the program, the after school
program, extended learning.
And I really felt good about
the work that we had done.
And then I personally got
involved in public education
and wanting to change it to
introduce computer science.
And I really learned
how amazingly difficult
is to change public education.
And so if there are two things
that stand out now about Eric,
one is the incredible courage
it takes to have a vision
and turn it into a
program that you really
want to institute major change
in how education is done.
And not just turning
around schools,
but actually engaging
broadly with schools.
And the second piece
is the tenacity.
I think he founded Citizen
Schools in '95 I think.
So that's almost 20
years of working on this.
And I just think the
commitment that that
takes with such a difficult
program of introducing
something truly new into
the public school systems
is amazing.
And it's not just something
that's going on in Boston.
It's not something that's just
going on in Massachusetts.
It's going on in several
states across the country.
And scaling the
organization's what's
really the big
initiative right now.
So he's written a book called
"The Opportunity Equation."
It wasn't the easiest name.
It wasn't my first choice.
But the book is available
to you for $10 over here,
which is a subsidized price.
Obviously it's available
on Google Play.
Google Books is a phenomenal
place to read digital content.
So at some point, that would be
a good consideration as well.
It's my great pleasure to
introduce Eric Schwarz.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHWARZ: That's awesome.
Steven, thank you so much.
I learned from
Steven many things
about data, about heart,
building a great culture.
Learned that you could wear
jeans to work every day too.
Now that I've moved on from the
CEO role of Citizen Schools,
I'm getting more
comfortable with.
But I want to thank, before
getting into the book
and what it's
about, thank really
the people of Google,
which is what's
made this relationship amazing.
And we've built a
relationship that
started in Mountain View,
grew here in Cambridge,
was really the next
place where it took hold,
and now it's in New York,
and Chicago, and other parts
of the country as well.
And we've had probably
about 1,000 Googlers,
many in this office,
others across the country,
who've gotten involved.
And the heart
connection as well as
the brain connection to
the work has been awesome.
I hope it is a growing
experience for the Googlers
who mentor kids in
Citizen Schools.
I know it is for the students
as I saw an email this morning
with Alan Su, who is a
colleague with many of you
here in Cambridge who was one
of the early volunteers here.
He's out in Seattle now
working with you guys.
And he said he misses a
lot of things about Boston.
He didn't mentioned
you, Steve, but he
said he misses a lot of things
about Cambridge and Boston.
And one of the main things
is his participation
in citizen schools.
But I want to thank Steven.
And Steven needs to go to have
a conversation with the head
of the state network of
superintendents as part
of the work he's
doing in education.
So appreciate you being
here to do the introduction.
Coming a little bit
later is another person
I want to think
just in absentia,
and that's Steven Rothstein,
who is as of two days
ago, the new CEO
of Citizen Schools.
And I have been laboring on
this for almost 20 years.
And it's been a labor
of love, and I'm
staying involved on
the board, but going on
to start a new venture
in higher education.
But it is so satisfying
and gratifying
to be able to pass the baton
to a really skilled leader who
started Citizens Energy with Joe
Kennedy some 20 plus years ago,
ran Perkins School
for the Blind,
and grew it into the largest
international organization
focused on blindness education.
So at the end of this you'll
get a chance to meet Steven,
and he's terrific.
So a couple things
about the book
"The Opportunity Equation"--
I think the title
was that difficult,
but Steven did.
There's true issues,
two mega trends
that the book is responding
to and the Citizen Schools
is responding to.
And the first mega trend
is a dramatically growing,
fast growing gap
between the achievement
of upper and lower income kids.
And even over the
last 50 years as we've
been able to reduce
somewhat the achievement
gap in this country based on
race, it's still way too big.
But it's half the size
it was 50 years ago.
The gap in reading
skills, in math skills,
in college graduation rates
between upper and lower income
kids has gotten not a little
bit bigger, but twice as big.
So there's a lot of
books about that.
There's books about that, but
that's an underlying theme
that the book
ultimately addresses.
The second underlying
theme that sort of
talk about in the
introduction of the book
is the greater consequence
for the country
and for individuals of
that growing inequality.
And when I grew up, the benefit
of getting a college education
versus a high school
education was actually
somewhat modest in terms
of your lifelong earnings.
You earned about
25% or 30% more.
Someone with a high school
graduate and a good work ethic
could get a good job, and
join the middle class,
and buy a house.
And that's generally
not true today.
And today, a college
graduate earns twice as much
as a high school graduate.
So the consequence
for individuals
is much greater for this
growing education gap.
And the fact that
for low income kids
the college graduation
rate has grown
from 6% a generation
ago to just 8%
today while it's almost
doubled for upper income kids
has huge consequences for
individuals and our country.
McKinsey, the consulting
firm, estimates
that we have a 3% to 5%
permanent recession imposed
on our economy by the
fact that we're not
able to lift up low income kids
to where their middle income
peers are.
Steven, how are you?
Just introduced you
in absentia, this
is Steven Rothstein, new
CEO of Citizen Schools.
So those are some of
the underlying themes
that the book addresses.
But what's the book's about is
well, what's causing this gap?
What is causing this
dramatically larger achievement
gap that I think is really
undermining the American dream,
and presents real
challenges for this country
in the next
generation and beyond?
And there have been
two major theories
about what's causing
the growing gap.
And the first is just poverty,
the growing economic gap
and poverty.
And while it's true that
poverty is highly correlated
to lower educational
outcomes, I don't
think it's right to
say that that's really
the cause of the
gap because there
are so many examples of
students living in poverty who,
when provided with the right
assets and the right resources
in learning, blossom and
achieve at high levels,
and do move on to
finish high school,
finish college at the same rates
as their middle income peers.
And Citizen Schools is
one great example of that.
The other theory that's
out there as to what's
causing this sort
of achievement gap
is that it's teachers,
and bad teachers,
and teachers' unions
undermining our public schools.
But in both these cases,
the poverty explanation
and the teacher
explanation, while they're
challenges we have
to wrestle with,
if you really
examine the issues,
it doesn't add up that would
be causing the growing gap.
Poor kids are not
learning less than they
were 20, or 30, or 40 years ago.
They're actually learning
a little bit more.
But upper income kids
are learning much more.
And unions aren't
stronger, and teachers
aren't worse or less
qualified than they
were 20, or 30, or 40 years ago.
My kids are getting
a great public school
education in Brookline.
There's many, many schools
with unionized teachers
in different kinds
of districts who
are delivering a
great education.
The real difference I
think is that a whole array
of leadership and
learning opportunities
that upper income kids
are getting out of school.
So that's really what
the book is about,
is looking at front from
birth to age four, five,
six, seven years old, upper
income kids increasingly
in just the last
generation getting
enrolled in Russian math
classes and Kumon math classes,
getting involved as they're
seven, eight, nine, twelve
years old in special enrichment
programs, robotics camps.
My daughter, as an
11-year-old, went last summer
for 3 and 1/2 weeks
to Argentina and was
singing across the country.
And she wrote back and
said dad, this is the life.
I'm getting asked
for autographs,
I'm traveling around in a
bus, I'm like a rock star.
And that's a cool experience
as an 11-year-old girl.
And that was
something we paid for,
and we organized, and got her
into that singing program.
My son this summer went to
Germany with a basketball team
and got to tour around the
country, and visit Dachau.
And that's an
incredible experience.
So the book chronicles
this dazzling array
of extra learning opportunities
that kids like mine,
and the kids in
communities like Brookline,
and many kids in
Cambridge take for granted
and are driving a bigger
and bigger achievement gap.
And it's academics, but it's
also participation in church.
30 years ago, low income
kids were actually
more likely to go to
church or synagogue
and have the social capital
that comes with that.
Today, upper income
kids are 50% more
likely to be on church
on any given weekend.
And with that column
social capital,
with that comes
connections that help
move you through high
school and through college.
It's jobs.
When I grew up, my wife, and
I talk about her a little bit
in the book, I'd grown up as
a privileged kid in New York
with a huge number
of opportunities.
She grew up a first generation
immigrant, very low income
family in Hudson, Massachusetts.
And she started working at age
11 in different summer jobs
and lied about her age to get
other summer jobs after having
a paper route, had
about 10 jobs before she
went to Tufts where
she graduated.
And that ladder of opportunity
is increasingly not
there for lower income kids.
It's 1/3 of kids today
who work in the summer
in their teenage years
as opposed to 2/3.
Upper income kids
get internships.
They find a way to
get a connection.
They get an unpaid internship
at Citizen Schools, or Google,
or elsewhere, and
that helps drive them
ahead to greater places.
And for lower
income kids, they're
not always getting
access to that.
So the book's a lot about that.
I use several vehicles to
get at that idea of what
I call an opportunity
equation, that when
you put in front of kids this
vast array of opportunities
out of school it, with almost
mathematical precision,
leads those kids to success.
And first couple
chapters of the book
are from my own story,
which is a story of a shock
and awe of persistent
opportunity overcoming
early failure, that
was quite persistent
as well in my life as
a terrible student,
but got so many
opportunities out
of school that helped
me move through that.
Talk a little bit about my
wife, the opportunity she had.
And then really, the next
part, or the first half
of the book, most of the
first half of the book
is about the development
of Citizen Schools
and the great work
that we've done here
in Boston and across
the country lifting up
opportunity, and really
providing for low income
kids what upper income kids take
for granted, which is as simple
an explanation of what Citizen
Schools does as there is.
You guys from Google, teaming
up with AmeriCorps members,
teaming up with financial
advisors with Fidelity,
and grandmothers
who know how to sew,
coming together, helping
kids be successful,
helping kids have
lots of chances
to participate in
great careers and learn
about all kinds of opportunities
that they didn't even know
were out there, much
less available to them.
So I want to share a couple
excerpts from the book,
and this first one is about one
of our early Citizen teachers,
a man named Joel.
And we've had Citizen
teachers in rocket science,
and journalism, and
financial wizardry,
and many people doing
Android apps and other things
here at Google.
Joel was a carpenter.
Joel Bennett had a
gentle smile, and a truck
full of saws, vice grips,
files, and other tools
to use in a burgeoning carpentry
and cabinet making business.
And Joel's business
was stable, and he
liked the feeling of
tangible accomplishment
he got from working with wood.
But when he met
Stephanie Davilosa
at a community
event near his home
in Boston's Jamaica
Plain's section,
Joel volunteered
that he'd always
been curious about teaching.
Sometimes after completing
yet another kitchen renovation
or set of built in
bookcases for a home office,
he wondered if teaching children
might be a more satisfying way
to spend his days.
Citizen Schools became a way to
dip his toe into the education
world, and he signed up to
teach a carpentry apprenticeship
in the spring of 1996.
That spring, we offered
a Saturday program
at Dorchester's
Woodrow Wilson School
four blocks from the
Victorian fixer upper Maureen
and I were soon to buy
in nearby Ashmont Hill.
We enrolled 64 students and
offered eight apprenticeships
in the morning followed
by various field trips
and learning activities
in the afternoon.
Joel's team of young
carpenters set out
to produce high quality
carpenter's tool boxes.
They measured them,
cut them, sanded them,
shellaced them, the whole thing.
The kids learned plenty.
Those of us observing
learned a couple things too.
For starters, we learned
that a few the kids
didn't know how
to measure at all.
In the second week, Joel
asked a seventh grader
named Kiehl to cut a
piece of wood in half.
And Kiehl said, half?
What's half?
Kiehl was getting B's at the
Woodrow Wilson Middle School,
and he didn't know
what half meant.
I couldn't believe it.
Joel broke down the
concept of half.
I remember him folding
a piece of paper
and then measuring his
two feet compared to one
before pulling
out a tape measure
and actually addressing
the piece of wood at hand.
Kiehl and Joel cut the
piece of wood together,
then they moved forward.
Francisco was another young
boy in the apprenticeship.
He was 11, and a recent
immigrant from Central America.
His toolbox was a
beautiful piece of work.
Around week nine, the kids were
planning their presentations
and deciding what
their tool boxes would
be used for, gifts
to their moms,
or just additions to their
own personal work spaces.
And Joel had noticed that
on the side of his toolbox,
Fransisco had written,
"Miguel" in big, block letters.
Joel hadn't heard him
talk about a Miguel.
So he asked him,
Francisco, who's Miguel?
I thought you were keeping
this or giving it to your mom.
Miguel's this old man who
lives in my neighborhood,
said Francisco.
He's always doing
nice things for me.
He gets me ice cream.
Last summer, he took me
out to a baseball game.
I've never had anything
to give to him,
so I'm going to give
this toolbox to Miguel.
Francisco's story has
stuck with me ever since.
Even after telling his
story dozens of times,
I still get goosebumps
imagining Francisco
presenting his
toolbox to Miguel.
Our society embraces the giving
of gifts to our children,
but kids want the chance
to give gifts too.
Kids who grew up with the
privilege of private classes
in ceramics, jewelry,
woodworking, or even music
have plenty of
chances to be givers
of presence they
created themselves.
Providing kids the chance to
be makers of things, not just
consumers, is an important part
of the opportunity equation.
So Joel actually went
to teach a number
of additional
apprenticeships, and then
actually did become a teacher
in the Boston public schools,
which is not our goal.
We think it's fantastic for
folks to stay at Google,
or stay as carpenters.
But we also think it's a cool
avenue into teaching as well.
So I want to read, I have to
read at least a brief passage
about someone from
Google who's volunteered.
So I want to read a little
bit about Alan Sue who
was one of a number
of volunteers
who taught many, many classes
at the Edwards Middle School
in Charlestown, which was the
beginning of Citizen School's
effort to move from an
after school program
where we worked with 50
or 70 kids in a school.
It made a big
difference for them,
but didn't fundamentally
change the school to what we
call an expanded learning
time school model.
Every kid in the school moves
from getting out at 1:30,
which believe it or not,
is when Boston kids get out
for the day, to getting
out at 4:30 or 5:00.
So we're now doing that in 30
schools around the country.
And that started at
the Edwards School,
and Google was a
big, big part of it.
Equally, and the school went
from being literally the lowest
performing school in Boston
to the highest in a three year
period from 17 families,
choosing at 450 families,
choosing at a total
transformation.
Equally important factors
in the school's turnaround
were the hundreds of
volunteer citizen teachers
who led apprenticeship courses,
people like David Mantis.
Mantis taught rocket science
seven times at the Edwards,
forging hundreds
of relationships
with students like Adam Beriga.
Tony Healey is the
retired businessman
who advised Principal Sabin in
the early years of the Edward's
turnaround, taught astronomy
at Citizen Schools 15 times,
including multiple
times at Edwards.
And Alan Sue, a whiz kid
engineer at Google's Cambridge
office, taught computer
programming classes five times
at the Eddie.
So if you know Alan, tell
him he's a whiz kid engineer
if he didn't know it already.
Sue is such a talent that even
as a relatively young engineer,
Google tapped him to
help lead the team that
made YouTube, a Google
subsidiary, faster,
helping the company live stream
every event at the 2012 London
Olympics.
But teaching was tougher
than Sue expected.
He taught his first
apprenticeship at the Edwards
the first year of
expanded learning time.
And Sue remembers
feeling a little naive
when he realized the web design
curriculum he had put together
was over the heads of most
of the students in his class,
and that many of his student's
didn't seem motivated to learn.
Despite the challenge Sue
committed to teach again,
his next course involved
creation of a public service
app for the Android
phone, an app that
would enhance the
experience for participants
in First Night, a popular
Boston Arts Festival.
The idea said Sue, was to make
First Night more interactive,
and to drive up attendance.
You could imagine a clue
on the ice sculptures,
and then people would
have to take a picture
to show they were there.
The students learned the
basics of putting together
a user interface and basic
computer programming.
And by the time
they were done, they
had the bones of
a really cool app.
Susan's come back to
teach three more times,
and said he's seen a
transformation at the Edwards
and in its students.
It's palpable, the difference
in the attitude of the kids,
it's night and day.
There's no more too
cool for school,
and now the students see that
learning can be really fun.
Sue said that his personal
motivation to volunteer's
grown too.
The thing I love is the
combination of the boots
on the ground experience,
the experience
of introducing kids to
something out of the ordinary,
and helping them realize
that the web is not
just something to consume from.
They can be creators too.
I love the combination of
getting to know the kids,
and also seeing the
results at the Edwards
which are incontrovertible.
I also love that I have
a role in addressing
one of the greater
inequities in our society.
Alan and all the volunteers
who've been involved
have done a ton to
address the inequities.
And Citizen Schools
has now created
a proof point in
about 30 schools
across 11, 12 districts
around the country
where we're delivering similar
results or better results
to the top charter schools and
to top private schools in terms
of growth in student
learning per year.
And the question,
and the question
of the second half of the book
is, how can we scale that?
And what really are the
key dimensions there,
and how do we grow both
through citizen schools
and other similar programs,
similar experiences
so that a generation
from now it can
be the new normal that all
kids in urban communities
have a longer learning day,
that all kids have many more
mentors, that all kids have
every chance to discover
and achieve their dreams, which
is our mission, bless you.
In the second half of the book,
we talk about five themes,
five building blocks
for student learning.
And not going to go
into all of them,
but I'll read short passages
around one or two of them.
But one of them is just
supporting teachers.
Urban teachers work
incredibly hard.
Middle school teachers might
have five classes of 30 kids.
How do you talk to parents?
How do you build individual
relationships with kids?
When you have an AmeriCorps
member helping you out,
it gives you a chance
to do pull out tutoring,
it gives you someone
who can reach out
to the parents at
night, it gives you
someone who can get the
kids more motivated to learn
in their regular classes
because they see how math ties
into designing an app for the
Android phone, which is pretty
cool, and makes the
kid more motivated.
So there's a chapter about that.
There's a chapter about social
capital and social skills.
And we think of that as
maybe an exotic thing
that Robert Putnam
studies at Harvard.
But the truth is that social
capital and social skills
are at least as important as
math skills and writing skills
to getting ahead in
the work role today.
But we haven't organized
schools to build those skills.
And Citizen Schools brings
a whole new dimension
into schools where in an
expanded learning time
environment, kids are
building their networks.
They're learning how
to work with adults,
they're learning how
to ask questions,
learning how to work with
teammates in different ways.
There's a whole chapter in
the book about creativity
and the massive mismatch
in our education
system between teaching kids how
to repeat facts, which is still
most of what school's about, and
teaching kids how to innovate,
and create, and design
things where there's
no playbook, which is what
you guys do all the time,
and what most jobs
in the future,
most good jobs are
going to require.
So how do you build the
skill to create and innovate?
You practice.
But how do you practice?
You create when you're a kid.
So Citizen Schools
through the apprenticeship
gives kids lots of chances.
And we talk through the
whole chapter about that.
The core underpinning of
the Citizen Schools idea
is the notion of more time,
more time for learning.
And Malcolm Gladwell's
idea is that sometimes you
just need those 10,000 hours
to get goo at anything.
And one of the biggest
differences between upper
and lower income kids is while
their school day is the same,
their learning day
is very different.
My kids get out of
school at not 1:30,
but 2:15 in the afternoon.
But then they've got a lot
of supervised homework,
they've got all
kinds of enrichment,
all kinds of activities
in the afternoon.
So more time, I
think it just has
to become the new normal
in America's urban schools
that kids have a nine
or 10 hour learning day,
and we bring to them
all the enrichment
of their upper income
peers take for granted.
I just want to read one
story about a particular kid
and some of the benefits
of a longer day.
Extra time's particularly
important for English language
learners who need more chances
to use English in real world
context and for special
education students who often
need expert intervention
from trained professionals,
as well as more personal
attention and guidance,
and extra time to
master academic content.
But the extra time
can be stressful too,
adding more opportunity
for conflict and challenge.
Tyrique, a special
needs student enrolled
in one of our Boston ELT
schools, is a case in point.
In many ways, Tyrique fits
my favorite description
of a middle schooler as having
the full emotional range
of an Italian aria packed into
the attention span of a knat.
Tyrique has the capacity to
show that full emotional range.
But when our staff
first encountered him
in the fall of 2012, most
of what we saw was anger.
He spent most of his first
semester in middle school
getting kicked out of the
classroom at all times of day
for swearing, breaking
things, and fighting
with other students in
a separate education
group, the therapeutic
learning community.
He could often be
seen storming down
the hallway to the timeout
room, paraprofessionals hurrying
behind to help him calm down
and redirect his behavior so
that he could reenter
the classroom.
Tyrique lacked the patience
and emotional skills
to cope with his frustration
in a healthy way,
and he lacked the desire
to do well in his classes.
He ripped up tests
and broke pencils
to avoid performing
academic tasks.
His grades and scores
were rock bottom.
I've met a lot of kids like
Tyrique over the years,
and typically school does
not work out well for them.
They have emotional issues,
or attention issues,
or organizational issues,
or reading issues,
or all of the above.
For medical reasons
and sometimes because
of severe daily
trauma in their lives,
tasks like listening
to instructions,
and following directions,
and working in groups,
and doing multi-step
problems are really hard.
Some days they just can't do it.
They're so angry they feel like
their head's going to explode.
And it gets even harder
because classmates
in their special needs
cluster have similar problems,
so they reinforce and add
to each other's challenges.
Further, they all
noticed that they
are in the therapeutic learning
community, or the learning
adaptive behavior cluster, or
just the special needs class.
And they feel ashamed.
In the cafeteria,
other students call
them the dumb kids,
or the weird kids,
or used sped as an epithet
and avert their gaze
as they walk through.
When they sign up for a
sports team, which is rare,
they often get kicked off the
team for yelling at the coach,
or not following a play, or
for some other transgression.
Tyrique's school had
some uncommonly good
special education teachers.
But his lack of emotional
control and intense struggles
with executive function
were on full display
when he entered his
Citizen's Schools classroom
at the end of each
day last fall,
the first year of
mandatory expanded learning
time at the McCormick
Middle School.
When he was assigned to
the soccer apprenticeship
on Thursday
afternoons, he refused
to enter the classroom
the first week.
In the second week he
entered reluctantly,
unleashing a torrent
of curse words.
It was the same story
when guests would come in
to help teach the apprenticeship
such as Pat Kirby, then
the executive director of
Citizen Schools, Massachusetts.
Kirby, a college
level soccer player,
remembers casually ignoring
Tyrique's initial stream
of foul language, and
encouraging him to participate,
to share his knowledge
of sports statistics
and the play in the
scrimmage at the end
of the lesson,
something he'd never
done in any previous week.
Kirby arrived in the fourth
week of the apprenticeship,
and his presence
marked the first
in a series of turning
points for Tyrique.
According to his Citizen's
School's team leader,
Tyrique talked about
his positive experience
in soccer all week long.
In a world devoid of
positive male role models,
Tyrique came to depend
on Kirby, his new mentor.
He started to open up in
his soccer apprenticeship
looking forward to it
each week, and earning
the title of Team MVP in the
final Wild Bowl Tournament.
He went from literally
standing on the sidelines
of the game, reluctant
to enter the fray,
to running into the
chaos and helping
to score the winning goal.
In the spring, Tyrique rejoined
the soccer apprenticeship,
and served as the team captain.
He took his new
role very seriously,
rarely swearing, and
impressing teachers
with his growing emotional
maturity and his kindness
to other students on the field.
For someone who initially seemed
unable to display any empathy,
actions he now took such as
using the word "we" to refer
to his teammates and helping
people up when they fell
were big developments.
Tyrique's improved
behavior started
to spread to his regular
Citizen School's team
too and eventually, to his
performance in the classroom.
He started to
improve his grades.
And one day, when Pat
Kirby came in to visit him,
Tyrique bragged about earning a
perfect score on a recent math
test.
Tyrique's only
hesitation in playing
on the soccer team in the spring
was missing the opportunity
to be in the camping
apprenticeship which
was held at the same time.
To build on Tyrique's
momentum however,
Citizen Schools staff
agreed that after the soccer
apprenticeship
ended, he could join
in the last few
weeks of camping.
And if his behavior
kept improving,
could participate
in the camping.
Wow, an authentic,
overnight camping
experience in the
Blue Hills Reservation
about 10 miles outside Boston.
Tyrique was initially weary
of the many deprivations
involved in camping.
But when the
camping day came, he
was eventually
laughing and running
around with new friends.
He recruited others
to watch the sunset
over Ponkapoag Pond,
which he described
as peaceful and beautiful.
He slept through the
night in his tent,
and completed an eight
mile hike the next day.
Tyrique told his team
leader during a quiet moment
on the trip that
during the past year,
having more time to work
with people like her
and Mr. Kirby helped
me work on my behavior.
And now Mr. White, the
coordinator of the TLC program,
wants me to do regular
education classes next year.
She asked him, are you
scared for next year?
And he replied, no.
I already have friends
that are older than me,
and he named several
of the other students
on the camping trip and from
his sports apprenticeship teams.
For Tyrique and other students,
expanded learning time
gives them time to slow down,
to literally and figuratively
watch the sunset and
soak in some extra time
with a mentor, a teacher, or
an interesting assignment.
So I wanted to share
that story just
to give you a sense of
the impact you can have
as a citizen volunteer on
one kid and on the country.
And the book goes on
to talk, and finishes
with a call to action to people
who work at Google, to people
who work in offices, and
retirees, and college
students across the
country to get involved,
because we are not going to
build an opportunity society.
We're not going to erase
that growing achievement
gap by waiting
for a better test,
by waiting for a better
online education program,
by waiting for
some better policy
to come out of Beacon Hill
or out of Washington, DC.
We're going to lift
up our schools,
and we're going to lift
up opportunity only
through the one thing that's
ever really changed things
in a big way in this country,
which is citizen leadership.
And from the citizen soldiers
who put down their pitchforks
and picked up their muskets
to defeat the British army
and create this country
to the abolitionists,
to the suffragette leaders, to
the civil rights citizens who
led The Civil Rights Movement
that has done so much to make
this a better
country, this country
has only moved forward
in powerful ways
when average citizens like
all of us in this room
have gotten involved
and gotten engaged.
And I want to ask you,
many you are already
involved with Citizen Schools.
But stay involved, volunteer
with other programs.
Volunteer as a big
brother, a big sister
at National Academies
Foundation, at Citizen Schools,
at US 2020.
Get engaged, get
people to buy this book
and to talk about this book,
and to think differently
about education, not as
something to wring our hands
about with all the challenges,
but as something to be excited
that we have today, thousands
of examples of success
which we did not
have 20 years ago.
Citizen Schools, and you guys
are helping to create that.
So my request to you is, think
about how you can build up
Citizen Schools, how you can get
people talking about this book,
how you can get your own
family and other people you
know to be more involved
as active citizens.
Because that is
the one thing that
has the power to move
this country forward
and to lift up opportunity.
And that's a really important
thing for this country to do.
So thank you so
much for being here.
We have some time I think for
some questions or dialogue,
and I really appreciate the
help of everyone in the room,
and appreciate you coming here
before lunch on a Thursday
morning.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So have maybe 15 minutes for
any questions, or dialogue,
or discussions, or thoughts
that any of you have.
Yes?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I have a
somewhat selfish question,
but I'm going to ask it anyway.
I'm a parent in the Cambridge
Public School System.
ERIC SCHWARZ: OK.
AUDIENCE: I believe
very strongly
in the potential of
that school system,
and I'm just curious if you're
talking to Jeffrey Young
or working with anyone there
about the Citizen Schools
Program.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Yeah, thank you.
We are not talking right
now to folks in Cambridge,
and we're working in the Chelsea
School System and the Boston
School System, and really trying
to grow our efforts there.
But one of the things that
Steven is really, I think,
excited to do is
to think about what
are the various ways
that we can support--
we can bring this
model or elements of it
to many more places?
One of the things that
I'm proud that we've
launched in the
last few years is
an initiative called US 2020.
And that is an initiative that
we've worked with the Cambridge
Public schools on,
and it's an effort
to massively scale mentoring
in science, technology,
engineering, and math.
Imagine millions of STEM
professionals working
with kids in Cambridge
schools, in Boston schools,
and all over the country.
And they might be working the
expanded learning time hours,
or at 9:00 in the morning
alongside a teacher,
or after school.
But that's something that
I've had some conversations
with the mayor of
Cambridge and others,
and they have some interest.
So maybe I'll help there.
And I want Citizen
Schools to be omnipresent.
So you should talk
to Steven afterwards,
get the superintendent or
others to be in touch directly
with him and with--
Amy Sargent is here
from the Massachusetts
team, and others.
Because that's the
conversation we want to have.
And whether it's just
some ideas around how
things that are already
happening in the schools
could be tweaked a little bit
to bring more creative thinking,
longer learning day, more
chances for mentorship
for kids, that's great.
We can advise a little bit.
But the idea of bringing the
full fledged Citizen Schools
Program to the Cambridge
schools that need it most
is something we certainly
wouldn't rule out as well.
So thanks for your
leadership in Cambridge,
and thanks for the question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I know in the book you
talk about actually the school
in Boston, the Eddie, where
Allen Sue was volunteering,
and the incredible turnaround
it had going from something that
was about to be closed to
something that actually got
a lot of national praise
for how strong of a school
it was after a couple years of
Citizen Schools being involved.
What are some of your favorite
turnaround stories of not just
individual students having
breakthroughs, but schools
like that having breakthroughs,
and a school level
change that your program
has been able to help with?
ERIC SCHWARZ: That's
great, thank you.
So a couple I mentioned
are homegrown right here.
Edwards was the first, and I
just alluded to a little bit
in the talk.
But this was a school
that as Travis mentioned,
was very close to
being closed down.
In a three year period before
they started Expanded Learning
Time, there were 53 assaults
of teachers by students.
It was the lowest or second
lowest performing school
on all the different metrics,
test scores and parent demand,
across the Boston system.
And they didn't get
a new principle,
they had they had some
turnover in their teachers,
but not wholesale turnover.
What they got was a
9 and 1/2 hour day.
What they got is every kid
in middle school taking
four apprenticeships a year.
What they got is every kid
in middle school having
an extra hour of math
instruction every day
led by Citizen School's
AmeriCorps members.
And that combination
of the extra academics,
the extra enrichment
totally changed
things, the spirit
of the school.
They had a football team,
they had a cheerleading squad.
Spirit of the school
took off, and it
went to one of the most
oversubscribed schools,
big waiting list, erased
80% of the achievement gap
with suburban
schools in English,
and reverse the
achievement gap in math.
And that was the first
school turnaround
story that convinced
us as an organization
we need to move from working
with some kids in the school
to working with all kids.
And that can really then be
not only an innovative model
around the edges of
public education,
but a fundamental change to the
offering of public education
and really bringing
into urban schools
and integrating within them a
lot of what upper middle class
families have managed
to create in combination
with public schools
in their communities.
A couple years after
that, Orchard Gardens
replaced the Edwards as
the lowest performing
school in Boston.
It was in the bottom five
or six performing schools
in the whole state
of Massachusetts.
And that became a
turnaround school.
So there actually
were a fair amount
of new teachers in that school.
But also, they moved to
a 10 hour learning day.
And at the middle school
level, Citizen Schools
was the lead partner.
And while they've had
a real improvement
across all the grades,
K through eight school,
the middle school
grades have taken off.
And it went from being one
of the lowest performing
schools in Boston to literally
the highest growth scores
of any school in the
state of Massachusetts
three years after doing
Expanded Learning Time.
So that was an incredible story.
We now have-- the new
principal at that school,
is a former Citizen
Schools campus director.
She worked at the
McCormick School,
and that's sort of
early stage turnaround.
But I know a lot of Googlers
have worked at the McCormick.
That's where we
started 20 years ago.
And that school, the data
that's about to come out
on the MCAS in sixth, and
seventh, and eighth grade,
amazing growth scores-- some of
the highest in the city, some
of the highest in the
state for a school
that also was not too far
away from being closed,
and really struggling.
There've been others in
East Palo Alto, in Chicago
last year, our kids showed
almost two full years
of learning growth as
opposed to typical of one
year across four schools
that were in Chicago.
So a number of
schools, and we're
excited to now have a handful
of school superintendents.
If Cambridge joins the list,
that'd be great, saying we
want to make this normal.
We want to invest in this.
We know it's not going
to come for free,
but we want to
think differently.
We want to really think
outside of the box
and not tinker with
the school system.
That's what generally gets done.
People just add a little
bit, subtract a little bit,
the budget's pretty
much next year
what it was last year,
but think much differently
and really think about a
much longer learning day, not
a little bit longer
learning day.
Much different
set of activities,
whole different talent model.
And we now have proof positive
in the 30 plus schools
that when you do that, even
with some of the toughest
to reach kids in
some of the toughest
neighborhoods in
the country, you
can deliver outstanding results.
So thanks Travis,
for that question.
One or two more questions
or comments from anyone?
AUDIENCE: So you said the
first part of your book
is about citizen schools, the
second part is what comes next.
So what comes next
for you, Eric Schwarz?
ERIC SCHWARZ: Oh, wow,
thank you, thank you.
So I'm going to join
the Steven Rothstein fan
club as the charter member.
It's going to be my main
job for the next year.
And that's partly
serious, mostly serious.
But the book tours
for the next month
will pretty much be consuming.
I've got 31 events
in 30 days everywhere
from the Dever-McCormick
School, to the White House,
to Google events in
three different cities.
And that's going to be really
exciting and also exhausting.
Hoping to take a few
months off after that.
And then what I'm
looking to do next
is to innovate in the
higher education area,
and to really bring some of the
same themes of Citizen Schools
to higher education,
experiential learning.
So create a college where kids
are getting half or maybe even
more than half their
credits through internships
and externships that they
reflect on, and to give them
real world experience
in public service.
Just like we have
Citizen teachers,
have Citizen professors so
that people who know a lot,
have a lot of insights, but
haven't become full time
professors have a chance
to teach one of course
a year at this college.
And it'll start as a partnership
with the existing colleges,
and eventually, the goals is to
become an independent college.
So that's my goal
for my full time job.
I'm going to stay on the
board of Citizen Schools
and be a lifelong,
deep champion.
And I think Citizen
Schools is frankly
at a really exciting
inflection point.
We've got this
initial proof point.
We've got an amazing team.
Stevens an incredible
visionary leader.
And I think you're going to
hear so much more about Citizen
Schools in the years ahead.
And really, we have a chance
to become the new normal
in urban education
across the country,
be the new kindergarten.
50 years ago, kindergarten
was not taken for granted.
Now, it is.
That should be the same thing.
Maybe 20 years now,
Expanded Learning Time
should be taken for granted.
And when we do that and we do
that in a high quality way,
we will lift up opportunity
for every kid in the country.
So I'm going to stop there.
I'm here, there's book's here.
I'm donating all author
proceeds to Citizen Schools.
So when you buy a book you not
only get subsidized by Google,
but you help subsidize
Citizen Schools.
So buy one or two, and the great
folks from the Porter Square
Bookstore are here.
And this is a former Googler, I
think, who's running the store.
So thank you for being
here, and thank you
all for taking the
time to come today.
Appreciate it.